squared minus 2x plus one being divided
by X plus three okay so we're going to
set this up we've got X plus three is
going into x squared minus 2x plus one
okay what you want to do is you want to
see like how many times does X go into x
squared okay or you can think about
working backwards you could say what
times X is x squared you want to try to
match this first term because when you
subtract you want to eliminate this
first term so that's going to be X and
then we're going to do is you're going
to distribute x times X is x squared x
times 3 is 3x and then what you want to
do is you want to subtract now what a
lot of teachers will teach and a lot of
students will do is they'll change the
signs to the opposite and then they're
add because subtraction is just like
adding the opposite so you can see that
these cancel and we get negative 5x plus
1 okay so now we have to say okay what
times X is negative 5x or you could say
how many times is X going to negative 5x
or what's negative 5x divided by X well
that's going to be negative 5 and we're
going to distribute the negative 5 to
both these terms so that gives us
negative 5x minus 15 I'm going to change
the science to the opposite and I'm
going to add so that comes out to 16 now
see how 16 is the zeroth degree this is
just a constant this is the first degree
X to the first this is a lower degree
than this so this is a remainder so our
final answer is going to be X minus 5
plus our remainder over our divisor so
you take your remainder over what you're
dividing by so this is your final answer
now you can see X plus 3 didn't go in
evenly because we did have a remainder
but you just take that remainder and put
it over the divisor like I was showing
you in the long division problems that
we did a long time ago ok so now let's
take a look at another example 2x minus
1 is dividing into this long polynomial
same process we're gonna see how many
times does 2x go into 4x cubed and
that's going to be
- x squared ok notice I'm lining up the
X Squared's just to keep things
organized okay so I'm going to
distribute that gives us 4x cubed minus
2x squared I'm going to change the signs
to the opposite and add that's really
just like subtracting so we get negative
6x squared plus 6x plus 10 okay now I
say how many times does 2x go into
negative six x squared that's negative
3x and I'm going to distribute okay to
both these terms so it's negative 6x
squared plus 3x I'm going to change the
science to the opposite and add and so
that gives us 3x Plus 10 and then now
we're trying to see how many times does
2x go into 3x that one's a little bit
trickier that's three halves I'm going
to distribute we get three X minus three
halves change the signs to the opposite
and add and so that's going to give us
10 is really like 20 halves plus 3 is 23
halves this is a constant this is a
lower degree than two x's so that's our
remainder and we're just going to put
our remainder over what we're dividing
by our divisor and that's it so this
right here is our quotient which is just
another way of saying the answer okay
this is how many times this went in to
our polynomial and that's it so this is
how you do polynomial long division I'll
see in the next video